I remember I really for set for some
reason I wanted to be like a TV and film
snob I don't know why I wanted to be
like I've seen everything did you go
through the oh I think I feel like
everyone's gone at this point every
beauty everybody I feel like you knew
was it was in it I just finished
watching like 24 in prison break and I
was feeling like man I'm such a TV
connoisseur I've watched Prison Break in
24 so I went to went through the list
and and Death Note was like eight or
something at the time
Wow nice and I this must have been like
2000 yeah 1213 yeah and I skipped it or
initially cuz I'm like watching [ __ ]
cartoons yeah I'm a grown-ass man I grew
up cuz real again cuz like you know my
parents and they're all my family and
cousins and whatever like they were
telling you like dude stop watching
cartoons alright you're alright
so I I initially skipped it but for some
reason I did a double take like two or
three weeks later read the synopsis and
I thought okay this sounds pretty
[ __ ] sick yeah yeah and if it's in
the top ten it's got to be pretty good
right yeah watched one episode I I had
to school the next day but I stayed up
the whole night up until school I had to
leave with two episodes left to watch i
binge did the whole season of death no
yeah one night and oh my god I just
immediately feel I became obsessed like
it was like over I I had just come like
all my other plans to watch all these
famous movies and TV shows yeah get that
out of here someone on YouTube said
watch Code Geass so I'm gonna do that
and it's just like obviously that phase
where you discover all like the golden
anime it's just like Bangor after Bangor
and it's like three months straight
where you're just like all you think
about is watching the next Anam good
like remember that fake I've missed that
form so much everything she watched was
amazing you know like I look back at
some of the [ __ ] now like going through
this phase well I was I was obsessed
with Love Hina right okay if we all had
that face back of the day can I ask what
was the show that ruined that for you do
you remember because I know exactly what
it was for me not because like I feel
like once you watched enough anime or
you start like do you remember the
feeling of the void right avoid where
you watch this really really good show
you're like no
gonna top this not nothing's gonna top
this and you just feel empty
hit your boo oh and then and then the
more shows you watched more the more
that void shrinks right they were like
you find the next amazing show bro you
were like and then you watch enough and
then you find like your top 10 favorite
shows and then that's that's kind of
when it starts cementing for me to like
to the next phase where you start
watching stuff and it's not as good a
feeling as when you first started so
what was it for you then school days